>> Greg: RACIST BAKERY.
BUT AFTER SLANDERING THE
CIVILIANS THE COLLEGE MUST NOW
PAY MILLIONS.
FINALLY THE PRICE OF BEING WOKE
MIGHT BE GOING BROKE.
IN OHIO APPEALS COURT ARE THEY
ALL.
APPEALED A $32 MILLION VICTORY
FOR GIBSON'S BAKERY OVER FALSE
RACISM ACCUSATIONS LEVELED
AGAINST THESE MOM-AND-POP SHOPS.
THE CASE GOES BACK TO 2016 WHEN
THE BAKERIES OWNERS SON STOPPED
THREE BLACK STUDENTS ONE OF WHOM
WAS STEALING WINE FROM THE
STORE.
SO WAIT THE BAKERY ALSO SELLS
WINE?
WHAT IS THIS PLACE HEAVEN?
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WILL THAT LEAD THE
PRO-TASTE AGAINST THE BAKERY IN
2017, MET RECENTLY THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
AMONG THE PROTESTERS WAS THE
DEAN OF STUDENTS WHO HANDED OUT
FLYERS TELLING PEOPLE TO SHOP
ELSEWHERE AND ACCUSING THE
BAKERY OF RACIAL PROFILING.
THE BAKERY OWNERS SOLD THEM OF
ACCUSING ITS REPUTATION WITH
FALSE ACCUSATIONS.
AFTER LEGAL BATTLE A THREE-JUDGE
PANEL LOOSE AGAINST THE COLLEGE
UP HOLDING THE BILLION-DOLLAR
RULING.
SO THE GIBSON'S WILL HAVE THEIR
CAKE AND A PILE OF DOUGH AS
WELL.
AND 30 MILLION IS WHAT WILL GET
FROM A COLLEGE VERSION.
SO NOW THEY KNOW THE COST OF
WOKE IS PRECISELY $32 MILLION.
COINCIDENTALLY THAT'S THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY I SPENT LAST
YEAR ON CHARITY.
THAT'S HER STAGE NAME.
ANYWAY.
BECAUSE SHE'S A STRIPPER.
MICHELLE, YOU GOT TO LOVE THE
STORY COMING FROM BERKELEY
RIGHT?
BERKELEY ALUM.
>> Michele: I LOVE WINE I LOVE
CAKE AND THAT IS HEAVEN.
I DREAM OF CAKE SOMETIMES.
AT THIS DREAM WHERE THERE'S
TABLES AND CABLES OF CAKE.
[LAUGHS]
LOGOS AND GOT HIJACKED BY THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT RACE.
NO IT WASN'T.
I READ RECENTLY THAT SOMEONE
COMPARED WOKE US TO TO THE SALEM
WITCH TRIALS WHICH LASTED ABOUT
WHAT 18 MONTHS OR SOMETHING BACK
IN THE 1690s OR WHENEVER THAT
WAS.
AND THE REASON WHY THE SALEM
WITCH TRIALS AND IT WAS BECAUSE
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR IN
MASSACHUSETTS HIS WIFE WAS
ACCUSED OF BEING A WITCH AND
FINALLY IT HIT HOME AND IT'S
LIKE OKAY NOW IF THEN.
I FEEL LIKE MAYBE THIS WOKE IS
HIM WILL FINALLY COME TO AN END
WOKE WAS ORIGINALLY SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT BEING AWARE OF SOCIAL
ISSUES GOT HIJACKED IN A BIG WAY
MORE LIKE OVERLAND.
>> Greg: THANKS.
FEELS LIKE A SHIRT.
I THINK SHE'S BEING SINCERE.
>> Kat: TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AT LIKE A LOT OF MONEY.
>> Greg: WELL FOR YOU.
WILL FOR YOU.
>> Kat: YES, INCLUDING ME.
I DON'T HAVE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS YET.
BUT I JUST LOVE THE RESPONSE
THAT I GET THE ARGUMENT GOING
FREE SPEECH AND ALL THAT.
LIBEL ISN'T FREE SPEECH?
AND THEM COMING OUT OF SAYING
THAT THE SECOND% FREE SPEECH
CONCERN WHICH IS NOT A CONCERN
THAT THEY'VE EVER PRESENTED.
EVER.
THAT SCHOOL AS THE LOCUST OF THE
WOKE AND THE FACT THAT EVERYONE
OF YOU TO THING.
LONG HISTORY OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION.
DISCRIMINATION WITHOUT LOOKING
IN THIS ACTUALLY NO HISTORY OF
THAT.
BUT THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LONG AND NO.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THIS COULD BE THE
WORST THING THAT THEY'VE EVER
DONE THEY SAID THAT LENA DONE
HIM THAT'S THE WORST INCOME OF
OVERLAND.
WAS LISA DUNHAM.
SO FAR.
>> OF THE IDIOTS THAT THEY'RE
PAYING WITH FINANCIAL AID ABOUT
$80,000 A YEAR TO GO THERE TO
ACCUSE A SMALL BUSINESS OF
RACISM WHEN YOU GET CAUGHT
STEALING WHICH IS ACTUALLY WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE SHOPLIFTING
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> Dagen: THAT'S WHY THE
SECRET HE GUARDS JUST STAND
THERE AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN THE STORE AND LIKE OKAY
HAVE A $70,000 IN LUGGAGE THAT
YOU JUST STOLE BECAUSE I WANT MY
ENTIRE LIVELIHOOD RUINED BY YOU
CALLING ME A BIGOT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED, TODAY I
BOUGHT A GIBSON'S BAKERY AND
CANDY SHOP T-SHIRT SO THEY GOT
AN EXTRA $42 FOR ME AND SOME
AWARE TO BE MY OWN PERSONAL BITE
MAY.
IF YOU'RE TO DESTROY BUSINESSES
BECAUSE YOU SHOW A PAUCITY OF
WOKENESS.
>> Greg: I CAN'T HELP BUT THAT
PURGES THE T-SHIRT.
THOUGH SHE LOVED DOG WHISTLES?
>> Bret: FLICK OF THE DETAILS
OF THIS STORY IF YOU GO BACK TO
THE REAL ORIGINAL CASE.
IT'S EGREGIOUS.
THE FACT THAT THIS BAKERY IS NOW
GETTING'S PAYMENT ITS REVERSE
JUSTICE IN THE BIG COSMOS.
THE POLITICALLY WOKE IS HIM IS
NOT SELLING WITH DEMOCRATS.
WHEN YOU SEE AL SHARPTON SAYING
THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY SICK OF
RED ELITISTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT'S A RED ALERT BECAUSE
POLITICS IS SHIFTING.
IT'S AT THE POINT WHERE IT'S
GREAT THAT THEY GOT THIS MONEY
BUT I THINK THE OWNER PASSED
AWAY CORRECT?
SO HE DIDN'T LIVE TO SEE THIS
BUT HOPEFULLY HE'S GOT A LOT OF
MONEY BUT MAYBE IF THE STORY
GETS PUBLICIZED, CALLING
SOMEBODY OVER A SYSTEM RUNNING
THEIR CAREERS, IF THE PAY FOR
THAT.
>> WASHINGTON POSTED TO
NICHOLAS.
>> Greg: COMING UP RESEARCHERS
HA